There have been a number of high-profile plagiarism
scandals in politics.
For example, in 2016, Melania Trump gave a
speech at the Republican National Convention,
that directly plagiarized a 2008 speech of
Michelle Obamas.
Here some of the text from Melania Trump.
You can see that it is a direct copy of Michelle
Obama's words.
Plagiarism is the practice of taking someone
else’s work or ideas and passing them off
as one's own.
Most people are aware that you shouldn't do
this, that it's unethical to plagiarize.
Where it gets murky, however, is that many
students aren't completely sure exactly what
constitutes plagiarism.
In this presentation, we are going to try
to make that clear.
What constitutes plagiarism?
Most people know that you shouldn't be stealing
large chunks of text from others, but plagiarism
can be more complex than that.
Cutting and pasting a sentence, or even a
part of a sentence from another source, and
putting that into your own work as if you've
written it, that's plagiarism.
Taking somebody else's work, and cutting and
pasting it into your document and then slightly
re-arranging the words or changing a word
here or there, that's plagiarism.
Borrowing descriptions or definitions directly
from Wikipedia, that's plagiarism.
Here is an example.
This is a Wikipedia entry on Ernest Hemingway.
It says, “Ernest Miller Hemingway was an
American author and journalist.
His economical and understated style had a
strong influence on 20th century fiction,
while his life of adventure and his public
image influenced later generations.”
Now, imagine a student is writing about Ernest
Hemingway.
So, they go to Wikipedia, and they start cutting
and pasting bits and pieces from the Wikipedia
entry and they come up with the following:
“Ernest Hemingway's thrifty and understated
style strongly influenced 20th century fiction.
His audacious lifestyle and public image also
influenced later generations.”
This is plagiarism.
Notice that the student substituted a few
words: thrifty for economical, audacious lifestyle
for life of adventure, and rearranged a few
things and changed a few other things, like
“had a strong influence” to “strongly
influenced”.
These changes are just cosmetic.
These are not the student’s own words.
These are not his or her thought.
These are the words and thoughts of the original
author.
One could have rewritten that text without
having any understanding of Hemingway or of
what a thrifty or understated style even means,
or what his lifestyle was.
When you're writing about others' ideas or
writing from sources, you need to understand
and digest the material well enough so that
you can put it in your own words.
This means you're probably going to need to
go to multiple sources to adequately understand
the subject matter.
As you're collecting source material, it's
okay to cut and paste passages from other
people's work to get everything in one place,
like in one word document.
But put those passages in quotation marks
so you don't later forget that those aren't
your words.
And when you go to write about it, work from
memory, never start with someone else's text
and just move their words around.
By the time you're ready to write, you should
understand the material well enough to be
able to start from scratch.
Draw your own conclusions, come up with your
own ideas on the topic.
That's what you need to do to avoid plagiarism.
Another thing that students are often less
aware of is the concept of self-plagiarism.
Self-plagiarism is recycling your own writing
or your own data from one published paper
to the next.
It's also unethical.
In addition, you may be violating copyright
laws from the journal that owns the published
paper.
You are not supposed to plagiarize even from
your own work.
One possible exception to this is that there
may be some duplication of text within the
materials and methods section.
For example, there may be only so many ways
to explain what you did to the cells.
So, if you've used the same experiment across
multiple studies, there may be some text repeated.
It shouldn't be a complete copy, but if you
explain some of the materials and methods
in the same way, in multiple papers, journal
editors are usually fine with that.
But everything else should be new.
Authors also sometimes engage in something
that's akin to plagiarism which is duplication
of their old results and their old data.
Sometimes an author will take a data set that's
already published, and maybe add a little
bit of new data, or tweak the data slightly,
and present the whole thing as a new paper.
This is misleading because it's putting things
out there as if they were two independent
pieces of information supporting a hypothesis
when there isn't.
It's padding the medical literature with superfluous
papers, and there's also, of course, a copyright
issue.
Interestingly, there are research being conducted
to go through the literature, and figure out
exactly how prevalent is plagiarism in the
scientific literature.
There was a story in Nature, where they reported
that in pilot tests of the plagiarism detection
software CrossCheck, some journals found that
6% to 23% of submitted manuscripts had to
be rejected due to plagiarism.
That is a very high percentage.
Another study used automatic detection software,
and then they manually confirmed plagiarism
in submitted papers.
They found that 8% of the papers had plagiarized
other people's work and about 3% involved
self-plagiarism.
So again, we're ranging around 10% of the
papers having significant plagiarism.
Another group of researchers did a study of
plagiarism in the personal statements for
residency applications.
These were doctors who were applying to do
their residency.
The researchers used a plagiarism detection
software to review about 5000 personal statements,
and then they confirmed suspected plagiarism
manually.
They found that 5% of essays had clear evidence
of plagiarism.
Meaning 1 in 20 of the doctors applying for
residency had plagiarized.
So, plagiarism is a significant problem.
Be careful in your own work to put everything
in your own words.
In summary, in order to write something original,
you have to go to enough sources so that you
can figure out for yourself, about the topic
you are writing.
You have to understand enough to be able to
generate new ideas, and that's what you need
to do to avoid plagiarism.